you've done a lot of research in this
area about what to do so do you know
where men go wrong with dating profiles
and what they should do
is it like photos they all they're all
they all have fish or something
there's a lot of fish on tinder i know
it's uh okay so so a couple thoughts so
so you mentioned before the the the
study that i had cited about how
um
so men tend to swipe right they tend to
like the profiles of
more than 60
of the women that they encounter whereas
um
women only swipe right on uh 4.5 right
so very you know as a guy you know it's
very very slim slim odds so
where they go wrong the fish picture is
interesting i talked to uh one of the
the former uh product guys at tinder
and
he told me that actually fish pro fish
pictures
tend to tend to actually do pretty well
uh surprisingly well and he thought it
was we both thought it was funny because
we're you know we're both aware that
there's this sort of trope that people
like fun of it like oh the guy with the
fish but apparently
yeah well you know and i make fun of it
too but i mean apparently if you have a
fish uh picture it does slightly
increase the chances for a guy you know
i don't know about how much but it's
it's better than average
um
other things that guys can do
[Music]
so so this is really interesting is
having a dog this is something that i
think we all know
um but it's actually a huge benefit uh
to have a dog
in your in your dating app picture
uh some i think something like um
you're twice as likely or it might have
been like 60 percent as likely
to to be liked if you have a dog picture
if you have a cat picture
um you're actually less likely to be
liked by a woman if you're a straight
guy so if you're straight guy looking
for a female partner having a cat is
detrimental so don't have a cat
apparently for gay men it's a little
different i think gay men actually
there's a they have a slight um
uh preference i think for guys who have
cats um but if you're straight guy uh
yeah don't uh don't put a cat get get
the dog um
one other thing uh
that guys could do and this is a little
bit more uh involved in burdensome than
just you know going out and asking your
friend to borrow his dog for a picture
is um
uh continue education
uh so there's research showing that uh
basically what these these guys did uh
these these scholars did what they they
took um
a picture of the same guy same profile
and the only thing that changed was
whether he had a bachelor's degree or a
master's degree
and the guy with a master's degree got
twice as many likes as the guy with the
bachelor's degree
and so yeah if you're
on the dating apps and you are you know
sort of serious about finding someone
then maybe uh getting a master's degree
would be would be wise i think a lot of
people are going to listen to this and
say oh just put master's degree on there
but you know she'd really you should
really get the master's degree
and it helps for women too surprisingly
i think a lot of people are uncertain
about the benefits of education for
women's romantic prospects but actually
um
women who get master's degrees they did
the same study in the same set of
researchers and found that women with a
master's degree get around i think 10
more likes than women with a bachelor's
degree so it's a slight advantage i
don't know if it's it's enough if you
know it justifies you know getting the
master's degree for 10 more likes
um but it is a slight uh a slight
advantage for them
and and then yeah just generally i've
i've seen other um this isn't research
but this is just like opinions i've seen
from women
uh that you know sort of the bathroom
selfie is is terrible get like good
pictures and those kinds of things
i've i found so so there's some
conflicting research here on
on um social proof
uh which which david bus has has uh
researched another thing so social proof
is basically um
a lot of research finds that if a guy is
in a picture
with with women
uh women who are observing the picture
rate him as more attractive than when
he's alone or with uh surrounded by guys
um and the idea here is that like oh
well if these women especially if these
are attractive women are willing to you
know be around this guy and tolerate
this guy then you know there's probably
something interesting about him or
something appealing about him so they'll
rate him as more attractive
um but then when it comes to dating uh
uh apps
guys who uh post pictures of themselves
on their apps surrounded by women uh
they tend to get fewer likes than when
they're alone or they're when they're
with guy friends
i'm not exactly sure what's going on
here i think one reason for this might
be that like
you know
women
women may not necessarily be super
interested like i think the picture may
convey that like this guy is unserious
or that he just wants to like have you
know short-term relationships one-night
stands he just wants to have flings and
that's why he has these pictures all
these women he's just
you know i think it gives maybe the
wrong the wrong vibe but this is you
know i i don't actually know it's just
speculation like why do you think this
would be
yeah well probably i mean if i looked at
that i'd
i think especially if the women were
attractive i think okay that's
potentially
competition and if you're on a dating
app already or like i just won't even
won't even get into that i think it's
probably that is like maybe that's
competition and or if you want to think
deeper about it well why is he showing
other women on his dating profile right
but i'd say competition probably if it's
attractive women
yeah yeah that makes sense i mean
yeah yeah so that that mismatch was was
intriguing to me i mean
in real life there's other research
showing
you know what guys can do to uh to
maximize their attractiveness or to
increase you know their their appeal
there was a research for example showing
that a guy who carries around um so they
basically had the guy the same guy
he would approach women carrying a
guitar case you know this case in the
shape of a guitar and he would ask women
you know he'd sort of start a short
conversation and then ask for their
number
um
and he you know he approached some
number of women doing it with the guitar
case and then he did the same thing you
know a few days later uh with different
women uh with nothing
uh just sort of carrying nothing just
being you know regular and so
when he had the guitar case he got um
many more numbers many more phone
numbers
and i i'd wondered i've never seen any
research on this i don't know of any
even anecdotal stories but you know if
you're a musician uh you know have a you
know have some you know carrying a
guitar or some kind of instrument
uh i think that might be you know that
might be uh
advantageous
probably depends on the instrument like
if you're carrying around a two bar i
don't know how that well that's gonna go
the uh a flute or uh yeah
clarinet yeah i mean maybe with the
clarinet i don't know probably not the
flute or the tuba
yeah yeah yeah i don't know
so what would be the most attractive
instruments do you think so i mean
probably yeah guitar but like how about
a piano like how would a piano look
saxophone might saxophone oh right yeah
there is the other sort of jazz and yeah
okay i can see that um
drums how would dru how do you think
women would see a guy with drums
oh i'd probably wondering why they were
carrying them all
well not not carrying but like by like
playing what i mean is like if you're on
the apps and you're sort of seeing that
or like on a website or something you
see a guy playing the drums i i think
like that might be you know i think
someone no i think that works i think
anything in in a band like that a guitar
a bass drums
anything like that would work
didn't one of the kardashians just and i
could have this wrong because i don't
really follow the kardashians but didn't
isn't one of them dating
oh this is a terrible story
that like rock guy who
plays the drums hold on
okay
hold on i need to know this travis
barker doesn't he play the drums
i mean the name rings is about a drummer
there we go i know i know things yeah
okay okay
kourtney kardashian dating travis barker
the drummer
so there you go there's an example
all right yeah yeah i think uh okay so
the drum yeah drum yeah that'll be that
that could be added to the list you know
learn an instrument
um maybe yeah i'm thinking of others so
i those are sort of all of the
empirically based suggestions that i
have but i'm thinking of others like
maybe cooking you know if you're seeing
in the kitchen and you're cooking or
making some elaborate meal or something
and i think some of these like these
would actually be worth studying beyond
just
you know beyond the sort of usual like
the dog picture or something you know
more education but like actual hobbies
and activities which i think a lot of
guys already know right like i think
you'll see um pictures of guys who post
you know like outdoors pictures or
skydiving or i think all of those i mean
it's really interesting i hope that
there are some researchers out there who
are looking into this about like
you know
what
what personality qualities is someone
conveying when they you know when they
have the the skydiving picture
i think um open ice
yeah i think openness maybe extroversion
yeah um
probably low neuroticism or higher
emotions
oh i i bet it's that i bet it's that for
something like skydiving
yeah yeah you're sort of showing like
courage and the absence of anxiety
yeah i mean so i've gone skydiving and
bungee jumping actually and i didn't
find skydiving that that's scary i think
budgie jumping is much more terrifying
but i think most people associate
skydiving with more terror so maybe
that's like a better maybe that's a
better picture
how was the landing i wanted to go
skydiving but i have like a fake hip and
a fake ankle and i figured that if
something broke people would just be
like yeah maybe don't do that
all right well okay so so the first like
i don't know however many times you go
skydiving you you do like a tandem jump
so you're actually attached to like a
professional skydiving instructor when
you land when you land yeah so you're
attached the entire time
and so like they basically are like
telling you like you know when to put
your feet up like how to do it when to
when to land and so on i don't know if
it would be because i know that you have
some you know health conditions and
stuff i don't know if that would be
worth uh risking though it could be
pretty tough i
i didn't have a problem with it but i
could imagine like if one little thing
goes wrong or like the wind blows at the
wrong time or something maybe it would
be but you'd have to talk to a
professional skydiving instructor to get
the details they're just straight up
gonna say no though
like this is like not definitely not you
oh well well you can go sky or you can
go you can go bungee jumping then you
know put that on put that on your uh you
know your webpage or whatever your your
your app page because i think it looks
cool like i mean i have some pictures i
this was years ago so i went skydiving
in 2009
before you know before all this you know
the dating app stuff had taken off but
you know i still managed to get some
cool pictures of jumping off the bridge
and stuff and i'm like you know that's
that's a cool picture
so yeah
yeah
that's good
that's good
um do you think
do you know any of the stats
about what's changed during covid for
dating apps like has dating app use gone
up because everyone's isolated or is
everyone actually isolated and scared of
dating now
do you know anything about that you know
i i don't have any stats um about
about whether it dropped i mean my my
guess is at least for the first couple
of months of the pandemic probably there
was a
uh sort of reduced use
but then like just anecdotally just from
like talking to my friends a lot of my
friends who are single and especially my
friends who are younger and still in
college
uh it seemed like you know there was
like a brief like eight week period of
oh let's you know be careful and then
they stopped and i mean i had a friend
who
so he he worked at a consultancy he was
right out of college in 2020
uh he went on furlough which is
basically
like you know they're paying him 20 to
not work anymore you know because they
were sort of reshuffling reorganizing
whatever and so they paid him 20 he took
a six-month furlough and he said for six
months straight all he did was was go on
the apps and bring a different uh person
over to his house every day
uh to have a date and whatever else so
so he did this for six months straight
basically throughout the entire you know
lockdown uh and this was in the u.s
and yeah he was telling me he was funny
he's like i was so uh grossed out with
myself during that period
um but i was bored and had nothing else
to do because i couldn't go anywhere do
anything all i had was the app so that
was my entertainment uh and uh yeah he
um
he ended up going on like this religious
retreat in israel
uh as a way to like like cleanse himself
of like all of his sids or all the stuff
that he had done he felt a little bit
repulsed about like just what he had and
so then he he was like i'm going to turn
over a new leaf i'm deleting the apps
i'm never going to do this again and
then he comes back from israel and he
said like within a week he downloaded
all the apps again he was doing the same
thing
um and all my other guy friends are
telling me the same stuff you know like
i think the people who actually had the
best you know the best time if you can
call it that
were people in relationships you know
like people who already had a party they
were just sort of chilling at home like
whatever watching netflix and hanging
out or whatever and like
the people who were um
you know trying to figure out the dating
apps and like whether or not to put like
i think tinder had this special
like a special feature for people who
were vaccinated to like signal that
they're vaccinated and
you know there's like a bunch of
interesting ways that guys
interact with the apps i don't know if
you've heard of uh you know
woke fishing
okay let's get into woke i think i've
peripherally heard of woke fishing but
what is that well
so you've probably heard about
catfishing right catfishing like
pretending to be someone else on the
internet on social media or whatever but
woke fishing it was this thing there
were a couple of articles about it uh i
think in vice and the new york post
basically uh
men pretending to be progressive to get
laid
uh and so they would put like you know
something of their tinder bio like you
know they'd put black lives matter or
you know climate change reform now or
something like that
and they would just sort of pretend to
do this but there were these stories of
like guys doing this you know putting
this and then they go on a date with a
girl and then later on
you know the women who were writing
these stories about this you know they'd
go home with a guy and find like books
by ann coulter on the bookshelf or like
a maga hat like stashed away in the
closet or something
[Music]
yeah yeah so he has the you know jurogan
app on his phone or something or the
spotify up with joe rogan and so
i
yeah i think like yeah a lot of guys
were sort of like
trying to figure out how to how to you
know get the attention of women and get
their interests
[Music]